as we said New York Chicago Atlanta
other cities and as Mike Tobin
highlighted hundreds mourning the death
of George Floyd during a memorial
service in Minneapolis earlier today
among the featured speakers the Reverend
Al Sharpton took time away from his busy
job at M s DNC to politicize the events
take a look we cannot use Bibles as a
prop and for those that have agendas
that are not about justice this family
will not let you use George as a prop
Tom about make America great great for
who and great win we gonna make America
great for everybody for the first time
perhaps a al Sharpton missed the
president's comments miss his early
demand for immediate justice the next of
expedited investigation FBI brought in
by the president DOJ brought in by the
President and the Civil Rights Division
to work with local law enforcement
authorities they were fired in record
time all four officers have now been
charged serious charges and we believe
that justice will be served
but they got fear division hatred blame
President Trump
everything's in Trump name by the way
and his home city Al Sharpton's is under
attack last night in the city of New
York two officers as I said were shot
another stabbed right in the neck
they were patrolling the streets of
Brooklyn for looters but authorities and
out probing the perpetrators possible
links to terrorists now after a week of
violence police have been shot run over
by cars beaten by mobs hit in the head
with bricks frozen water bottles and
other projectiles several members of law
enforcement have died some are fighting
for their lives that are in life support
with life-threatening injuries as we
speak but the chaos the Anarchy that
still continues now just last night
surveillance video capturing looters
ravaging a drone store in Manhattan this
is just one of hundreds of businesses
that were looted vandalized or set
ablaze over the past week and you have
the politics of this the left psychotic
so-called solution now to all the
violence at all the anarchy and
all the lawlessness and all the looting
and all the arson and violence is uh
let's get rid of the police altogether
because that is apparently now their new
battle cry they want to abolish police
officers Hillary Clinton's former
spokesperson Brian Fallon tweeting quote
defund the police and you got the
Hollywood Who's Who list let's see John
Legend Jane Fonda Liz Oh many other
celebrities signing an open letter
demanding that we defund the police
today the mayor of Los Angeles Eric
Garcetti the City Council vowing to cut
over a hundred million dollars from the
LAPD budget in New York at least 40 City
Council candidates are now calling for a
billion dollar cut to the NYPD in
Minneapolis City Council members are
actually vowing to dismantle the entire
police department and meanwhile black
lives matters we told you last night
they want to push all police out of
inner-city neighborhoods replace them
with their own armed militia this is the
same group we might recall that was
chanting what do we want dead cops when
do we want them now pigs in a blanket
fry them like bacon remember that chant
now this group wants armed self policing
seriously and without a doubt Democrats
seem to be embracing this anarchy today
the president responded he tweeted out
quote the radical left Democrats new
theme is deep on the police remember
that when you don't want crime
especially against you and your family
this is where sleepy Joe Biden is being
dragged by the socialists I'm complete
opposite more money for law enforcement
Senator Tom cotton he authored a op-ed
in The New York Times called for US
troops to be utilized to restore order
by the way the president saying he
doesn't think that will be necessary it
also brings up the issue of why these
cities and mayors and governors they are
saying to the president no we don't want
National Guard help they have to ask for
it and otherwise the president would
have to invoke an insurrection act which
I don't think is necessary and I don't
think we should have to do they should
be taking control of their own states
and cities now this has caused an
internal meltdown by the way with cotton
or op-ed to New York toilet paper times
some were apparent
apoplectic that The Times published a
viewpoint different than their own
liberal view the staff at the Times
claimed the words in the op-ed put
minority staff members in danger and the
toilet paper times ultimately
apologizing for publishing the op-ed now
today in a very kind gesture cotton
tweeted how's everyone at the New York
Times doing tonight I can report tonight
that they're not doing well because two
weeks ago the left was demanding that
police officers arrest anyone not
properly socially distancing and now
it's clear they want to get rid of all
cops altogether and it's coming at a
time where law enforcement is now
investigating whether or not Antipa is
organizing the violent elements in this
week's protests take a look there are
extremist agitators who are hijacking
the protests to pursue their own
separate and violent agenda we have
evidence that an Tifa and other similar
extremist groups as well as actors of a
variety of different political
persuasions have been involved in
instigating and participating in the
violent activity and we are also seeing
foreign actors playing all sides to
exacerbate the violence the AG is right
so what about this group and Tifa
who are these people and are they really
organizing violence all across the u.s.
all right we began a Hannity
investigation and Tifa
exposed because over the past week some
have been blaming Antipa for the all of
a sudden trace Gallagher has been
reporting about piles of bricks that are
staged showing up at protest sites all
across the country we've also witnessed
scenes of alleged Antipa members dressed
in all black wearing masks and helmet
all while breaking into stores smashing
windows spray-painting buildings and
assaulting the police in Houston Texas
Antipa has been accused of coordinating
the looting of a local target and
according to a lengthy undercover
investigation from Project Veritas James
O'Keefe organization Antipa has been
plotting and organizing violence for
quite some time